[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday and we are
back
well you know
yeah and today we're gonna do candy man
we just saw this uh yesterday we saw it
in the dolby theater yeah man went to
the dolby theater two o'clock in the
afternoon the first showing of it in our
area
because i think that was opening day
right no it opened friday
friday night yeah so it was just where
day two the first showing i think of day
two
didn't you say two o'clock is the first
year yeah yeah yeah for at least for
dobie yeah because i said well this is
one i'm actually really glad that we saw
this one in the theater because i think
one of the best things about it is the
visuals this is like an amazing looking
movie so you're getting into it already
no i'm just saying that it's like that's
why i'm glad we saw in the theater i
just thought i would say that yeah um
also
really you know we're thinking about
getting our uh stubs membership again
yeah because it looks like there's some
good [ __ ] like coming out and there's
stuff and like i said it's almost
october and that's usually like when a
lot of uh horror movies come out yeah we
saw a trailer for halloween kills which
that looks pretty good trailer for the
new uh venom looked really good yeah we
saw trailer for the new venom also we
saw the trailer for the new edgar wright
movie which was called what uh
one night in soho yeah that looks
intriguing
so uh yeah i think that was my favorite
of all of the trailers that we saw i'm
like ooh that looks weird it looks like
looks like something i'd be into
so um so we saw candy man i've seen the
original we saw it and we saw it new
when the very very first one came out
what was that 1992 92 the first one came
out yeah that was a great movie man it
was [ __ ] classic all right a good
storytelling it was just just a classic
movie that movie still stands
on its own feet today we saw it not well
last year well we did a retrospective on
it yeah probably about a year ago i
don't remember but yeah it wasn't that
long ago there's a part two but i don't
i've never seen there's a part two and a
part three i had forgotten uh part two
thank you no need for me too
um
the part two is called farewell to the
flesh and part three is called day of
the dead i thought that i hadn't seen
either one of them but then when i read
the wikipedia synopsis i was like oh
wait a minute i think i did see the
second one maybe a couple of times
because the plot sounded very familiar
um i remember it being okay but like
nothing to write home about like
yeah i don't think i saw the third one
but i've heard it's atrocious
even though tony todd is in all of them
yeah um i think that the third one day
of the dead has like nine percent on
rotten tomatoes or something like that
so
what i didn't know until i looked into
this a little bit more was that they've
actually uh bernard rose the guy who
directed the 1992 original he has been
wanting to make a real sequel to this
movie since way back in like 2004 where
he basically wanted to skip over
the second and third ones that already
got made and just like make a direct
sequel so this movie has taken that long
to go through like and it's gone through
like a zillion different iterations so
they've been like actually trying to get
this off the ground for like 20 years
almost so
candyman kind of took the same
trajectory as pumpkin head the first
one's the classic [ __ ] pumpkin head
two and three [ __ ] unwatchable well i
do kind of feel like with very few
exceptions and there are exceptions but
usually
uh you know when you have a franchise
like this uh you know it's usually like
the first one's awesome then they make
another one uh that was all right then
the third one's like man this is getting
really sucky and then by the time they
get to the fourth and fifth one you're
just like oh my god please just stop all
right so
this one is not a bad movie it it's a
mixture of really good and what in my
opinion bad
um overall it's mediocre um jenny liked
it i think more than i did yeah i didn't
love it but i totally thought it was
worth watching though but there was some
stuff that i thought could have been
could have been different or fixed but
overall i thought it was like a decent
watch overall i i say uh
i wouldn't pay to see it
if i was a fan of candyman one probably
wouldn't be wouldn't pay to see it
it like
we'll probably get into it further on in
in the review it's on you you know what
i mean [ __ ] i was
i had hurts i had heard some [ __ ] from
the like sneak reviews but
but i didn't
go out and look for it just in passing
some of the other channels that i
subscribed to mentioned it
and
it didn't sound good but i didn't want
to i wanted to go into the uh i wanted
to go into the uh into the theater with
a neutral view
it was not a painful movie it was it's
it's a it's a real good looking movie
the acting is very good
the casting is good
some of the cast members like that guy
who played flag and [ __ ] they really
stood out there was i don't think that
wasn't that was uh the guy from uh from
fear of the walking dead from fear of
the walking dead
what was his name flag right right no
that no that was that was from the stand
that's from the standpoint that's right
what was the name of that character from
i can't remember coleman domingo is the
actor's name yeah yeah anyway he's in it
um
and he's he actually shines in this
movie uh but there's not enough of him
that's the problem
uh the the other it's just the way the
story goes there's not a lot of
character development
uh the characters aren't too fun
um
it's just uh
man i don't want to spoil anything i
don't want there to be a bunch of spoils
or spoilers in here to me it was just
kind of disappointing because
it didn't give me the type of movie that
i was that i wanted to see in terms of
candyman you know what i mean it didn't
first of all todd's not he's in it but
not much
a few seconds really okay um
uh and it's at the very end and it's
just uh
he kind of made this character that
that's who i really kind of
i mean that dude's almost i don't know
try to do in a movie without him in it
without that voice
and without that kind of gothic horror
style of the very first one it's very
different this is a very 2021 movie
it is not
in the same tone as the first one
um it does have a bunch of kubrickian
stuff in it the way it was filmed i
thought was really cool it's the effects
when you see candyman are really cool i
like the ideas behind it i like certain
scenes that the candyman that he was in
there but the problem is there's just
not enough of it it's very dialogue
heavy
the first one was kind of like that too
it was yeah and i mean i was i was gonna
say that actually i think they did a
decent job at recapturing the tone from
the first one um the first one being set
in the world of academia this one being
set like more in the art world yeah
which i think they i think the second
one was kind of set in the art world as
well
like you know art galleries and stuff uh
if at least if i remember correctly so
it's like they are kind of like going
off of that so i think they did a good
job like
tonally but
i will agree that i think that they
should have done because
this isn't a real it's not a real gory
movie a lot of the kills kind of happen
like screens off screen or like you know
and it's it's artistically done which i
think is cool but i think sometimes like
people wanted to see maybe more of like
a slasher type element yeah um which
this is
i don't know i don't know if i'd call
the original candy man a slasher either
i guess it kind of is but it doesn't
like follow a lot of the tropes and i
think this is kind of the same this
along the same lines i don't even think
this is quite as bloody as the first one
no i don't think it is either now the
first one
now it's been a year since i've seen it
but the first one the tone that i
remembered and what stayed with me is
kind of like
a a silver screen
kind of like
monsters from universal studios like
dracula or
or this gothic horror like dracula or
frankenstein it kind of had a build up
along that lines it had a certain amount
of like tragic romance to it
uh it was there was a certain amount of
charm to the movie
this one i kind of felt kind of
ham-fisted that
one of the complaints i heard is that
the movie was [ __ ] woke all right i
don't
i don't i don't really think it was i
think maybe it was trying to be woke but
it's hard to say because well the thing
about it is kind of weird well the thing
about the original one
the original one was you know the whole
character of candyman is about racial
injustice that's where that so it's like
so i think that's kind of a dumb uh
complaint because that's kind of what
the character came from yeah but the
thing is though is that
you can't
never mind
but
you have to have like a consistent
philosophy to a movie if it's going to
be woke it can't contradict itself so
there i did pick up contradictions but
then some of the characters because the
characters are from the art world in
chicago they themselves are
kind of
woke and cringy the characters some of
the characters that are in there kind of
like that so you're not sure sometimes
they say things that kind of point out
um when you call it
uh contradictions and uh contradictions
inside their philosophy
so you don't know if that's an error in
the movie or if it's just a
misconception that that character has or
if it was a message it's it's some of
the things are very well it's kind of
it's it's self-aware
it's 20 21 so people are like kind of
aware of those types of things so
it's almost kind of like when they have
a character say something like that it's
almost like they have somebody else that
like points out so it's not like you
know you can't you can't
you can't counter or stop racial
injustice or hatred with more racial
injustice or hate and hatred if that
would be a vicious cycle in other words
like two wrongs don't make a right
you can't
you just
so but but was that part of the horror
element of the movie it's unclear
i guess you say it's philosophically
ambiguous it's so open to interpretation
but that's good yeah if that's what it
was it might have just been errors or
poor writing i don't know well i don't
think it was because it's just you know
well like i said jordan peele was one of
the writers on this he didn't direct it
which i think a lot of people uh have a
misconception about that uh nia de costa
directed it uh and she was one of the
writers on it as well
uh as well as when rosenfeld one thing i
was like i said i don't want to spoil
anything
but i do like
um and i had to it's funny because i had
totally forgotten this i do like the way
that they expanded the candyman mythos
out in the sense that
candyman since he's an urban legend
essentially um he can like he can be um
personified by different people
and i had totally forgotten that the
first movie kind of set that up because
at the end of the first movie if you
haven't seen the first movie from 1992
it's too bad i'm just going to spoil it
but virginia madsen
she dies at the end of the first one uh
you know saving the baby
and then she subsequently becomes a
candyman type character like her husband
like says her name five times in the
mirror and she pops out and kills him so
so there is like precedent for that i
also liked and like i said i think
somebody said earlier this that this was
a remake it's not a remake it's a sequel
uh it's a direct sequel to the first one
it's not and it's
essentially pretending that the second
and third one that everyone like said
were not that good um do not exist this
is basically and i don't think this is a
spoiler because i'm pretty sure they
said this in the first trailer that the
main character in this anthony is the
grown-up version of the baby from the
first movie so this is like this many
years later it's still set in chicago at
cabrini green although now cabrini green
has mostly been torn down um that
actually the the kind of ghetto part
where they filmed it that's that is
actually all that's left of cabrini
green so they did actually shoot it on
location um you know and so they kind of
talk about like you know ship being
gentrified and stuff like that because
you know yeah that was another one of
the things that kind of threw me for a
loop they were complaining about the
gentrification of the area
but when you looked at cabrini green it
was a look like a [ __ ] momentum
security [ __ ] prison work camp
and they were talking about how horrible
it was they didn't live there anymore
and they're saying this from inside
these beautifully furnished
[ __ ] high-rise apartments that
[ __ ] i could barely afford to live in
so what they want to go back to the hood
it didn't make any sense and then one of
the characters pointed that out but
happened to be a white character that
pointed that out and they didn't like
that
to some of the people in the comments
sections just saying jordan peele come
is is a racist um
if you were to take this movie and
switch the
the races around this would
be a horror movie equivalent of [ __ ]
birth of a nation
i do not agree with that whatsoever
that's they would attack it like that
what if you had a good
so you're either racist or you're not
racist you can't defeat racism with race
war and hatred you just can't and which
is it is it supporting that i don't know
it's open to interpretation
um
it's about a black ghost that kills
white people
that is a horror that is a horror story
i guess
well and the thing like i said too uh
they kind of went into
not so much gentrification in the first
one but they did point out that where
virginia madsen's character lived and
she was kind of like more upper middle
class like her husband um
their building was exactly the same
layout as the ones in capri green
because they had all been built at the
same time but because which actually
does um correspond with reality where
they built them all at the same time but
there was like a very fine line between
oh these are like the ghetto over here
and these are like the upper middle
class kind of [ __ ] over here so they did
kind of like go into that in the first
one
interestingly the first one like i don't
know if people know this but it was
based on a clyde barker short story uh
called the forbidden and um in his
version
it's actually set i think it's set in
liverpool i want to say like in a sense
like a housing estate uh so his is more
class-based than race-based but it's the
same
you know he was going for the same uh
type of thing
you know what i'm saying all
um you know philosophy or moralism aside
it's a high quality movie in the way
that was shot it looks good
the score is good uh the acting is very
good uh the casting is pretty good
um
the edit is a little meandering and kind
of artsy especially in the first half
but i think if i remember correctly the
first one was a little bit like that too
it was um
i think that the problem with the movie
is that
it's a horror movie and it's not scary i
didn't find it to be scary yeah i did
like
i did like some of the setups like
particularly when they have candyman i
like that they had like you said it was
almost kind of like
these kind of weird like kubricky and
like long shots and sometimes like he'd
be
in the mirror like in the background and
it wouldn't really like call attention
to it so it's like if you weren't really
looking
back there you wouldn't see it i really
loved that one particular shot where
that one woman gets killed in her
high-rise apartment and they just like
show it like as the camera's going back
and back and back and you just like and
it's very very small like i really
really like that i really loved um the
way instead of because they said we
didn't really want to put like just
dumbass like flashbacks in the movie um
or show parts from the original movie or
whatever like because that seemed kind
of cheap jack but um so i really like
that when they when somebody was telling
a story about candyman or something that
had happened in the past they had these
really cool um like shadow puppets
type of
shows which was really really cool i
like that they played a lot more with
the mirrors i like that they almost did
kind of like a um
uh nightmare on elm street type of thing
where it's like if you weren't looking
in the you could only see candyman in
the mirror uh but you know he was still
at times but you know well it depended
on who had summoned him there's also
some weird [ __ ] that was never really
made clear whether or not this was if
this was real or if this was
was this a real thing or like was it a
real ghost or was it people going crazy
and killing people it was kinda
how many how many of them were there
because there's more than one candyman
and another one gets made
and but they're all kind of merged into
the same thing it's kind of convoluted
well the point of it is that and like i
said easy to follow story it's not and i
will
i was gonna say that if you're gonna go
see it i would advise seeing the the
first one first because
i don't know like this one maybe could
stand up on its own but there is a lot
of reference back to the first one and
uh you know in the first one she's like
an anthropologist or something like that
so
the kind of the the whole um point of
the character is the power of myth
making and it's just kind of like and
the power of urban legends and how
so that's why i kind of liked that they
expanded it outward a little bit like i
said and kind of jumped off from the
first movie where she essentially like
took the mantle of candyman like
virginia madsen's character um so i kind
of like that they expanded that further
in this one it's just like every time
something like something candy man-like
happened like daniel robitaille who was
the original one played by tony todd
every time something like that happened
in this area like it's almost like a new
urban legend like sprang up about it so
it's kind of like the power of stories
to
bring things into reality and you know
and the first one explored that really
well too because like i said for a long
time you didn't know if candy man was
real or if helen lyle was just
had snapped and was killing people and
you know it was just telling because she
had like all this i mean obviously
you're supposed to think that candy
man's real because that would be lame if
it was just like all in her head and
stuff but
you know what i mean but that's kind of
like what uh what this is exploring i
will say that i think that
if i was re-editing this movie bryce not
a long movie i think it's only 90
minutes
yeah it seemed to be longer well i think
that they spent too long on the first
two acts and then the third act felt a
little bit rushed yeah um a little bit i
think it had budgetary problems if you
ask me uh i don't know well honestly it
costs 25 million which was this is funny
it got well it cost 25 million to make
which is the same amount that they were
going to make for it like when they were
going to make it back in 2004 so it
didn't get any more money but from what
i know like the opening weekend it seems
to have made more money than they were
expecting okay uh so far
and um so you know so they might end up
making another one i don't know because
they did leave the end open
uh if they wanted to make another one
they could
but i will say that there was some kind
of stuff one i think there was too many
characters um i know that they
introduced some characters just to have
them get killed um you know what i mean
they didn't really have a lot of they
just wanted canada at first that first
couple was the bearded guy the [ __ ]
gay the gay dude's boyfriend fooling
around with the white girls no no he was
he was um he was some kind of uh [ __ ] he
was some kind of professor art parent or
something like that and he was like
screwing around with yeah yeah um yeah
wasn't he hanging out with the black
dude though
wait i don't know which guy you're
talking about the two the the the the
the
the interracial gay couple that first
showed up right wasn't that the dude
from the interracial gay couple no oh
that was no that was a different dude
they all look alike to me
they all look like they're these soy
boys these little beards and [ __ ]
[ __ ] i thought that was the same
white dude no the other guy was like he
had a beard too but he was like taller
and chunkier they were both in the other
fat
no the no the the
that other the um the main character's
like uh brother's boyfriend wasn't fast
i thought they were this he was skinny i
thought they were the same and he was
but he was shorter okay and he had more
like kind of welcome back cotter type of
hair yeah yeah
but um
but you know what i mean so so i so i do
think there were some characters that
were introduced just to get killed yeah
that didn't really that didn't really
have anything to do with which you know
fine it's a slasher movie um you know
that they do that um i also here was a
weird thing too
there was a scene there was like a
flashback scene because they kind of
went into uh anthony's girlfriend uh
brianna
who she had started having nightmares
and [ __ ] like that as well as his as
he's because he's an artist and he uh
didn't know that he was the baby from
the first one um and he so he just kind
of gets fascinated by the urban legend
and starts using his work and stuff
which subsequently like ends up
introducing it to a new audience i guess
but the thing about it is that her is
that his girlfriend was also saying she
was having nightmares and then there was
this one flashback scene where she had a
dream or something like that like about
her dad
um killing himself and then they didn't
really bring that back up again so it's
like that probably could have been
unless i missed it that probably could
have just been left out because it
wasn't really relevant so that's what
i'm saying there was like i just think
there was a little too much they were
filling
well i just think there was a little too
much of character they should have and
they should have like put more on the
end yeah and like expanded the you know
the climax of it i feel like just
getting like the final battle just
started to get started it just started
to roll and i'll send it in but that's
really kind of like the main question
or something or what is it going to
continue in the next book
really what it was is i think it was
they didn't have the budget
cinema is about showing not telling but
they had to pad it out with a whole lot
of telling
um like i don't need i didn't need all
that dialogue about gentrification or
all that dialogue about racism we know
that that's wrong they don't need to
tell us that
just show the [ __ ] story and all this
[ __ ] that happens
but they couldn't because i think they
had to pat it out for budgetary reasons
it should have been just candyman
killing people
and it should have had some more a lot
more supernatural stuff but i don't
think they could have afforded it
because when they showed
when candyman showed up
the effects were [ __ ] good they were
cool like i said i love to see a whole
movie i loved all the [ __ ] they did with
mirrors because yeah the bees flying on
the inside of the mirrors oh yeah that
was super cool yeah
that was pretty good picking people up
invisibly and killing them but then you
can see certain things happening in the
mirror as you can see
uh
you can see candyman doing it there just
should have been a lot more of that a
lot more than a lot less of talking
about things it's just like you don't
really need a crt class people know all
that that's that's played out
um they've been talking about that [ __ ]
for [ __ ] five ten years now or five
years at least [ __ ] intensively so
you don't need crt classes all right
just [ __ ] show the [ __ ] movie
so
it bogged it down but i think it was
budgetary i think that's why they did it
because that's why that's why the edits
felt so [ __ ] wonky but the thing is
is it's kind of mar it's kind of
frustrating
because they had a good villain
they had a good cast and the acting was
solid the acting is good and and the way
it was shot was really cool
i loved loved the the cinematography and
the director and everything the problem
was the script the script and the edit
and and that and honestly i think it
probably could have been fixed like i
said there were some extraneous
uh characters like i said i kind of feel
like it would have been better if they
could have
if not taking out some of the what i
called the cannon fodder characters yeah
um at least integrating them into the
story a little bit more instead of this
them just being like oh i happen to be
here and like i summon candy man and
he's gonna kill me and stuff
okay they're in there going but still
you know does [ __ ] todd show up in
the movie there's a cameo right here he
does the cameo at the very end and they
do have virginia madsen's voiceover so
her voice is actually in it like um when
anthony is researching the case and he
finds her goes to the university library
and finds her tapes like from the
original one uh so she did actually
reprise her role at least in voice
but
you know it's i don't know i'd have to
go back and watch the first one again
even though it wasn't that long ago that
that i watched the first one because the
first one um
is kind of
it it's kind of slow too um in the same
sort of way but i think the first one
did a little bit better job of like
integrating all the characters that got
killed
um you know what i mean oh i will say
too vanessa williams who played ruthie
jean uh anthony's mom in the first movie
uh she's back in this one playing his
mom in this one as well and she looks
like she has not aged a [ __ ] day
she looks almost exactly the same and
it's like as soon as i saw her i was
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah how long ago
was that that was like 20 years ago she
still looks exactly the same no need for
me too says this still doesn't this
doesn't top nick cages the bees the bees
yeah i know
but yeah i mean overall it's like
um
i definitely think it's worth watching
um
i think that you probably
need to see the first one to
get the most out of this one because i
think there's some stuff in it that
maybe if you haven't seen the first one
um maybe you won't like get it or you'll
be like what the [ __ ] you might be kind
of lost i don't know it is you know
because i've seen the first one lots of
times um so
it's so i didn't have any trouble
following it or anything but it's like
if you haven't seen the first one but i
kind of feel like most people that were
like waiting to see this
were really into the character of
candyman and have seen the first one and
maybe even the other ones that you know
people don't really like to talk about
but you know what i mean so so i kind of
feel like maybe that won't be an issue i
don't know but you know
it's i don't know if it works as a
standalone or if you really have to sing
because like i said it is a sequel it's
not a remake yeah uh so you know what i
mean it's a it'll make its money back
probably um
i was i checked i checked rotten
tomatoes and you know
i think it's got like a [ __ ]
high 80s low 90s for the professional
reviewers you know you know talking
about how
stunning and brave it is the i guess uh
the
the regular viewers reviews i think are
in the 70s
and they're just kind of in
like it's okay you know but then there's
a lot of them just one stars that it was
just total crap
i think it was kind of in the middle i
think it was just kind of mediocre i was
disappointed because i
right when it started to rev up
and [ __ ] the cameo [ __ ] todd
happened
and he says his line i was like oh man
i'm finally getting the movie that i
[ __ ]
paid to see
and then it was over i was like oh no
when it ended i was like she just sent
me right next i was like oh no that's it
and it's just uh i was like all right
uh it's just
that character really hinges on [ __ ]
todd todd made that [ __ ] character
his look he's a hard act to follow that
voice is some he's like the james earl
jones of horror he can do that but
he i can't even do that she had that
deep [ __ ] voice and that's what made
this character he at least should have
done
the voiceover for it there should have
been more voice over
yeah they didn't do a lot of candy
voices should have done a bunch of candy
man voice even when he was invisible you
didn't have to see him you know because
you know he has
he's he's older now he did this when he
was young so you have to see him but his
voice there should have been a lot more
of that i i would have paid just to hear
his voice and him saying smart [ __ ] kind
of like freddie and a lot less of the
oh god please don't make him
say [ __ ] like freddie
where it started getting funny
hey well freddie [ __ ] he always had
to say some [ __ ] when he was gonna [ __ ]
yet but
but the todd todd's
candyman
is like a universal monster from
universal studios back in the day that's
at the level it's gotta be
and this movie just didn't deliver i
wouldn't pay to see this movie i did
like the actor that played candyman in
this one but like you said he didn't he
didn't really talk much yeah he didn't
tell him much um but i did like he was
like another candy man too he wasn't the
same candy man well yeah like i said it
was yeah that's kind of like the whole
point of the story was that the urban
legend had kind of grown and mutated
yeah and now it was like a different
boogie man it was a different guy
so it's not quite the same thing but
like i said it's hard to follow like
tony todd i was gonna say too i forgot
to say
i forgot to say that one of the things
that they were throwing around back in
the early 2000s uh which you know was
kind of like
not not really a great time for horror
movies i guess you know remember when
freddie and jason freddy versus jason
came out and it was like just this big
huge phenomenon so after that came out
and now everybody's like oh now we need
like all these like monster mashups like
in the early 2000s they were gonna do
candyman versus leprechaun
in the early 2000s
i mean
those are just two completely different
like the tote like totally different
franchises candy man and troll too i
just yeah i just think that would have
been stupid as [ __ ] yeah i mean freddy
versus jason okay fine they're both like
slasher villains it's fun [ __ ] like that
but like i said candyman seems more like
almost like a more cerebral type of
villain or a more cerebral type of uh
movie the first one was as well so it's
just kind of like doing that with like
this campy like leprechaun [ __ ] i don't
know who's like what kind of coke they
were snorting like to whoever came up
with that idea and thank christ they
didn't do it and you know honestly tony
todd even said at the time he's like
yeah i wouldn't have done that they had
asked me to do that i think i think with
this one the main problem was the budget
they couldn't do a whole lot of candy
man scenes uh they couldn't afford the
special effects
they just got some people together
and
made this movie on a budget
they had she got jordan peele involved
then they kind of 2021 pasted it on to
kind of like
blm
movement and just throw it out as a
product kind of like a cash grab that's
kind of even though they did
put effort in it it's just
the effort was focused around i think
keeping the budget down it was very like
i said 25 million dollars is not a lot
of money uh for a horror movie um
although like i said it doesn't have to
be super gory um and i liked the stylish
way that some of the kills were shot
yeah but you could have done more with
with the gore and i'm not saying there's
that there's not any in it there's some
in it yes um that the one set piece like
at the art gallery where that couple
gets killed like the the beardy guy and
the girl in the joy division shirt um
you know when they get killed that's
like pretty gory they show like you know
throat slashings and like the guys ankle
breaking and all this other stuff so
they so they do have stuff like that and
actually the um that whole setup for it
is really cool like the way because
there's all these projections on the
walls and like the red light and
everything i kind of think this will
move but this one's going to be
forgotten
yeah it's i don't know it's just kind of
like i i liked it i didn't love it yeah
um i think like i said i think my main
issue
was that like you said there was a a
little too much it was a little too
dialogue heavy a little too
um you know and not enough creepy [ __ ]
yeah
and and i just thought that you're not
getting the movie you thought you was
coming and then i thought that it's
still a horror movie for sure but it's
like and i thought the third act should
have been longer and the first two acts
you know not and like i said i kind of
feel like some of the characters that
got killed i wish they'd integrated them
into the story more rather than them
just being there to get killed by
candyman yeah and it's nothing against
jordan peel or anything [ __ ] i liked
the the movie us i liked that one
it was it was pretty good
but uh this doesn't hold a candle to it
out of the two i'd take [ __ ] us that
was a much better movie
us was weirder yeah it was a weirder
weirder
took me into another world you know what
i mean he had his own [ __ ] weird
world of a [ __ ] underworld and
you know some kind of um
jenny kind of explained to me i didn't
really get it at the time but it was
kind of in a kind of a
an analogy what do you call it oh [ __ ]
allegory yeah an allegory it's kind of
an allegory for [ __ ] um like class
differences that you could have been
high class or low class or whatever yeah
depending on an accident an accident
birth that there was another underground
and that was just kind of like a
kind of like a cool concept and not not
realistic but it didn't matter it was
just like a weird thing it's almost kind
of like a nightmarish experience to see
that movie because i've had dreams like
that
like open up my closet and find an
elevator inside my closet that take me
down into a [ __ ]
subterranean level of my house that i
didn't know existed you know
10 miles down and [ __ ] with monsters in
it
or a reproduction of my house but it's
dusty down in there and there's
weird [ __ ] you know i've had those
underground dreams before yeah but uh
it's kind of like that um
but no i'm just sorry you know i mean
it's
yeah no i wouldn't pay to see it i'd see
it for free
well like i said if you like candyman
it's still totally worth watching um
it depends on how like how much you like
him though
like well yeah but
every time i have an opinion on things
he's like i'm not allowed to have that
opinion you have opinion but i liked
candy man but he's like yeah
it depends that no just it depends on
what i still like the first one better
it depends it depends on what you're
looking for but i think this one was
better than what i remember of the
second one which i remember just being
like mediocre
this one was for sure was like a lot
better looking uh like i said i like the
score i liked at the end like during the
credits they actually used a little bit
of the original philip glass score from
the first one but like a different
variation on it i thought that was kind
of cool but there was just like a lot of
the visuals i think were like the best
part of this
um you know in the acting and everything
i really like some of the creepy shots i
just said like i i think they should
have just like rearranged and they
should have like taken out like i said
they should have taken out the stuff
about brianna
and her past and stuff because that
didn't really factor into the story at
all like they didn't really that wasn't
a through line so it's like some of that
stuff could have been taken out and they
could have you know put maybe more like
creepy candyman scenes in there that's
all that's really and it's not a huge
criticism but yeah i would give i would
give it that uh
you know what i mean
um
so for tomorrow
several people had had been uh bugging
me to watch brand new cherry flavor
on netflix the series
so i actually did start watching it i
watched most of i don't know how many uh
episodes
i know well i know because i i was
[ __ ] tired
[Laughter]
we got through about three or four of
them i think though no i think i i know
i watched more of them than that i think
i watched four or five of them um
yeah i'm really digging it so far it's
weird as [ __ ] i love that um but yeah so
uh so i'll probably talk so i'll finish
it up tonight and then we can talk about
that tomorrow um also what else was i
gonna say oh there was something else
that i think there was something that
came on shutter that was supposed to be
really good so maybe we can talk about
that one like later in the week too
but
yeah
and like i said there we saw like a
bunch of trailers for [ __ ] that was
coming out like in the next few months
and there's definitely some [ __ ] that
that i want to see when did was it
didn't tammy tell me what like when
antlers was coming out i don't know
i thought she said like october 27th or
something
i'd want to see venom that looked at
yeah that actually the trailer at least
looked better really good looked even
better than the first one yeah it looked
a lot better than their first i mean
that was that was a fun that was a fun
ass movie i also want to see like black
adam
and shazam too i think it is
going to be in shazam too is that how
he's supposed to be is that what it is
okay i don't know if it was his own
movie i didn't know when she i saw a
trailer for shazam too but i don't know
when it's gonna be coming out
so i don't know we'll see
grandpa's hammer says lamb looks dope
that looks like a weird [ __ ] movie
yeah well i saw it i don't think i don't
think you saw it that looks like weird
[ __ ] and i'm like oh that's yeah that
looks like something i'm gonna be uh
into you know what i mean yeah all right
so um
louis says jenny i saw a real good movie
on netflix it's called the old ways i
haven't heard of that one i'll have to
write that down so maybe i can watch
that one as well
i'm always looking for recommendations
even though i have a huge list of like
[ __ ] i still gotta get through but you
know but yeah so hopefully tonight i can
finish up pokemon brandy cherry flavor
so we can talk about that tomorrow
what's up pokey
all right so
uh i guess that'll oh my goodness bless
you
she's back there sneezing that's what
you get for like smelling stuff that has
dust on it look at her poking her a
little bit
all right so uh i guess that'll do it
right yep all right so have a good rest
of your weekend you guys and uh we'll be
back tomorrow afternoon for another
matinee show we'll see you then
bye